Good morning, John and Hank; it’s Friday!
So this October, I had my first music release
since my record came out three years ago.
I was on tour at the time and spent the hour
before the EP came out crying,
which I think was probably a surprise to my friends.
Which, you know, it does seem like a weird
response, but those and many of my other friends
also had releases coming out in the next couple
of months, and they all told me that they
had a similar experience the hours before
their EPs came out.
A few of my friends told me that releasing
something is a bit like giving birth: It’s painful,
which I think is like close to the—I
think that’s close to the feeling, but I
don’t think it’s quite right.
I think a better analogy is it’s a bit like
sending your kid off to college.
For a year, my art was mine to have and hold
and enjoy, and now it’s leaving and it doesn’t
belong to me anymore.
This is especially hard if you, like many
artists, put your identity in your art.
What if people don’t like it?
What if people think it’s not good enough?
What if people hate me?
It’s hard to create anything, and it’s
even ha—I don’t know if it’s even
harder to put it out.
They’re both very hard for similar reasons,
I think.
Before you go through the execution of making
something, it exists in your head, and in
your head, it’s a perfect idea, perfect
execution, perfect everything.
It’s beautiful.
But when you go through the pain of creating
something, you have to look into the face
of your inadequacy.
And sometimes this is like a lack of literal hardware,
you know, you couldn’t afford something you needed.
Or sometimes it’s: This is the first thing
I’ve ever made, and I don’t know how to do it well yet.
Here’s a quote from Ira Glass about being
a beginner and an artist: “Nobody tells
this to the people who are beginning.
I wish someone told me.
All of us who do creative work, we get into
it because we have good taste, but there is this gap.
For the first couple of years you make stuff,
it’s just not that good.
It’s trying to be good, it has potential,
but it’s not.
But your taste, the thing that got you in
the game, is still killer, and your taste
is why your work disappoints you.”
Ira Glass, I love you!
So yeah, I do think that this fear of inadequacy
and this fear of maybe rejection when it comes
to actual release is the reason that lots
of people never create at all.
It’s very vulnerable to say, “I made this,
and I like it.”
Maybe even more vulnerable to say, “I made
this, and I wanted to like it, but I don’t.”
But that’s part of learning, and that’s
a part of being a beginner.
I don’t know. What's my point here?
I guess my point is, it’s natural to grieve
the loss of ownership and the loss of the
safety of what something was before you put
it out.
And when creating, it’s natural to fear
your own inadequacy.
But neither of those are good reasons to not
try.
John, I’ll see you Friday.
Tuesday.
Oh, also, hi, my name’s Tessa Violet.
I make video blogs and original music. Ayyy.
I was on tour at the time
hello?